this video is sponsored by endl you can
train your brain just like you can train
your body and in many ways training your
brain will have a far bigger impact on
your performance and your everyday life
than will training muscle strength or
other similar physical properties now
there's some contention around things
like brain training programs but the
truth is the issue isn't that you can't
train your brain it's more that we don't
know precisely what the best input is
this is something we're going to be
talking about in this video specifically
when it comes to training the working
memory which is a crucial aspect of our
cognitive performance and by improving
your working memory you can process more
information think quicker come up with
better solutions to problems even have a
richer experience of the world around
you this is something that's a
particularly personal journey to me as
i'll explain in a moment but it's
something i've made a lot of progress
with and in this video i'm going to
explain how you can process more
information by training your working
memory effectively
so for those who haven't watched the
previous videos on this topic working
memory is essentially your brain's ram
this is where you store information in
order to manipulate it so for example if
you need to write down a phone number
then you hold that number in working
memory after you've been told it as you
look for your pen likewise if you're
performing maths use your working memory
to hold on to the numbers and carry
numbers over as you're manipulating that
information in your mind however we now
know that working memory is a lot more
complex than that and also a lot more
nuanced in particular that's because
working memory is cross-modal it isn't
just a matter of storing numbers or
storing words it's also a matter of
storing images and sounds and even your
body's position in space and you don't
just store these things in these
separate compartments you combine all of
them to create a more vivid and accurate
picture of the world around you so for
example if you're a football player and
you're running down pit trying to
remember where all the other footballers
are and where the ball might be by the
time you get to a certain point that's
using a working memory to store that
information in your mind's eye when
you're having a conversation use working
memory to store the context of
everything you've just said so that you
know what to say next it goes far deeper
than this though because we actually
also use working memory to literally
experience the world around us when you
look at something when you see a scene
in front of you you're not really
experiencing that scene directly you're
experiencing your brain's representation
of that scene and interestingly that
representation is actually quite
different from the reality and we use
our working memories to do this that's
because so much information is coming
into our brain at any one time simply
from our visual field alone there's no
way that we can process all of this and
in fact the resolution of our eyes gets
lower and lower as you move away from
the center from the fovea so what we
need to do instead is our eyes dart
around the scene taking small snapshots
of different individual things that we
can see and then glues those things
together in the working memory to create
our visual spatial landscape it combines
this with sounds which will identify
with particular images and your position
in space and at the same time it needs
to stitch all those things together with
your assumptions with your schemas with
your long-term memories a great example
of this is dreaming when we dream we
have no external stimuli with which to
update the information that we're
juggling therefore we create entire
worlds simply based on our working
memory these are fragile and permanent
creations held together by our sheer
brain power if you look at the time we
look away and then look back you'll find
that the time has changed because you
simply can't hold on to that much
information all at once this is kind of
what happens in our waking life the only
difference is that we have the ability
to look at things to update that
information and create a slightly more
accurate picture of the world around us
so as you can see your working memory is
partly responsible for your entire
richness of experience if you can't
stitch together as much information then
you have a more limited understanding of
the world around you it might even be
linked with consciousness itself and at
the same time you can have a huge impact
on things like your performance in
sports even in driving your working
memory could be really a limiting factor
and make you more dangerous on the road
what's absolutely crucial to effective
working memory is focus and that's why
i'm very pleased to introduce today's
sponsor endl so wendell is an app that
creates personalized atmospheric
soundscapes to not only help you focus
but also to help you to relax to improve
your creativity to help you to get to
sleep these are backed by scientific
research and studies show that using
endl when working can actually improve
your focus versus using a spotify
playlist and what's also really cool is
that the soundscapes are ai generated
and they respond in real time to things
like the weather the time of day and if
you have a compatible smartwatch they'll
even respond to your heart rate and they
have really cool collaborations with
different artists which are really
experimental and interesting to listen
to and if you use the link in the
description down below and are giving
away a free week of sound experiences so
you can try it out for yourself thanks
once again to endle for sponsoring this
video and now on with the show so can we
train working memory well our brains are
highly plastic we know that they're
capable of forming new connections and
new neurons late into adulthood
something that we didn't use to think
was possible this means that in theory
we can train our brains just like we can
train our bodies but as with training
our bodies for things like sports there
are some caveats here and some real
nuances in the way that we approach this
training because we need to train in a
way that has transfer near and far
transfer that is to say that if you
perform a brain training program and
it's just making you better at that
brain training program then this isn't
necessarily going to improve your
everyday life we need to find brain
training activities that actually
transfer to better performance in waking
life and this is where the issue really
comes in you can't just do lots of bench
press and expect to be able to do full
planche we need to train with
specificity for the goal that we have in
mind in the same way you can't just
perform say a dual end back test and
expect this to improve every aspect of
your brain function so again for those
who aren't familiar the dual and back
test is a program that challenges you to
remember numbers and to identify them in
a sequence dual mbac has been shown to
improve things like task switching which
is really useful under the right
settings at the same time it's been
shown to improve focus however another
study found that this doesn't
necessarily
improve overall fluid intelligence and
the issue is hopefully you've already
guessed that we're just training with
numbers here when we've already seen
that working memory involves all of our
sensors working together so at the same
time i'd be very surprised if performing
dual n-back would actually improve your
ability in sports for example so we want
to look at something slightly more
useful in that regard we might turn to
something like 3d object tracking and
here you have to track different objects
in your visual field there's a bunch of
good ones i really like react
performance trainer which is something
i've talked about on this channel before
and i play it often however this is
going to improve your visual spatial
landscape and i don't know quite how
much transfer it's going to have to
things like your ability to perform
maths sums the cool thing is studies
suggest that 3d object tracking can
improve things like player accuracy and
football but another study found that
doing 3d object tracking didn't even
transfer to other 3d object tracking
tasks the results a little bit mixed and
that was just one 3d object tracking
program we really need to look at the
bigger picture here and at the same time
i also find we need to look at other
aspects of working memory because it's
not just about capacity it's not just
about how much can you store in your
working memory it's also things like
persistence in the face of distraction
so in other words you can store that
information in your working memory but
when there's a noise in the background
or when someone's trying to get your
attention how easily can you hold on to
that information when you want to this
is why it's personal to me because i
have a lot of difficulty actually
switching between tasks i have this kind
of absent-minded professor persona and i
find myself being quite slow to respond
when someone speaks to me in the street
and i'm not expecting it i can be witty
in a conversation where i'm one-on-one
and i'm really focused on that
conversation but if someone just says hi
adam i'm like yes and then i feel like a
complete awkward weirdo as they walk off
scratching their heads likewise every
time i go to watch tv i'll sit down with
my wife and kids and i will just stare
at the screen whilst i try and remember
which app i'm supposed to be using it's
because i'm thinking about something
else and i struggle to clear out that
information it seems and then focus on
something new as a kid i was actually
put in the assisted learning class
because i was so disorganized and it's a
really odd and persistent issue with my
own brain function i'm just saying it
hasn't helped me back in life but it is
a big glaring issue and i'm actually
even looking into the possibility of add
or something along those lines so
perhaps training working memory could
help to overcome some of these
limitations just like i might say i
don't have as much mobility as i like
and so i'm going to train mobility
specifically so this has led me to want
to improve my own working memory so i
can be quicker in these kind of tasks
and more specifically i want to be able
to process more information quickly i
want to do task switch and i want to
generally be more alert and switched on
so to do this it might be helpful to
first look at how working memory
actually works and of course as is
always the case no one really knows
there are lots of different theories but
there isn't one that everyone can agree
on what we do know is there probably
isn't like a separate brain region a
separate store for working memory
descriptions of working memory such as
the visuospatial scratch pad might have
once made us think this could be the
case but as we now know
working memory involves lots of
different senses and essentially you're
keeping those neurons active in the
absence of external stimuli so in other
words you look at something or you
imagine something and that lights up
areas of your brain as though you're
still seeing it and then your job is to
hold on to that image by still focusing
on those neurons keeping that activity
going and this might be reliant on what
we call re-entrant loops in other words
the brain is looping around to keep
specific brain regions active so you can
maintain the image of what you want to
concentrate on brain imaging seems to
confirm that this is what's going on to
the extent that we see increased
fidelity in the image stored in working
memory correlated with increased brain
activity so the more we can activate the
brain regions that help us to visualize
or hear or work out as some the more
information we can experience these
loops likely involve the frontal regions
of the brain along with the posterior
cortical areas and subcortical
structures as well however the precise
brain areas being utilized likely is
determined by exactly the nature of the
task this is called the component
processes view of working memory and
it's just one leading theory but
essentially it says that we need to use
lots of different brain areas creating a
kind of loop to keep those active so
that we can maintain the image of what
we're trying to hold on to and it's
backed up by some studies that show that
damage to certain brain areas can lead
to deficits in certain types of working
memory specifically so in other words we
want to use all the different brain
regions however like i say there's no
consensus on precisely how working
memory works for example some models of
working memory suggest that it requires
fast hebian plasticity in the span of
milliseconds that's to say the brain is
actually rewiring itself using the same
rules it does for longer term plasticity
in real time as we're thinking this is
quite amazing to imagine that the brain
is literally rewiring self as we think
whether or not this means we don't need
activity in the brain as well and some
models are activity silent suggesting
that we don't need constant firing in
the relevant neurons that's up for
discussion but what we can take from
this is that there is a kind of loop
necessary working memory isn't just in
one part of the brain it's dispersed
across different brain regions and so we
need to train not only those individual
brain regions but also the connectivity
between them so looking now at something
like dual and back we can see why it's
not enough because we're just using one
aspect of our brain's function this is
why coming up with apps and tasks for
ourselves that involve multiple aspects
of our working memory could be the best
way to improve our cognitive processing
speed and capacity for example we know
that juggling has been shown in studies
to increase gray matter in brain regions
responsible for sports vision because
here you're not only using
proprioception to move your hands and
arms and consider your positions in
space you're also tracking the movement
of the balls with your eyes so there's a
lot more information here for the brain
to juggle however at the same time we
could up the challenge here by placing
ourselves on a wobble board for instance
and then having ourselves answer maths
problems whilst we're doing it now we're
using multiple different brain regions
all at once and we're trying to avoid
distraction hold on to multiple pieces
of information i think that this could
provide a much more intense stimulus in
order to encourage that kind of brain
rewiring this is something i'll be
trying and i'd love for you guys to try
it as well and we'll make it an
experiment you guys can let me know in
the comments down below whether you have
any luck with it alternatively we could
also apply this to creating brain
training programs but trying to improve
their effectiveness i thinking in terms
of multiple different sensory inputs in
terms of progressive overload intensity
and all these things
challenging not only capacity but also
persistence against distraction etc
and put it all into a single package
like that i think virtual reality makes
a lot of sense for this because it has a
much wider field of view because it
takes into account your movements as
well however i do think we could achieve
this to a lesser extent with an app for
example so i've built an app myself that
i want to share with you guys you can
find a link to in the description down
below it's completely free however if
you would like to donate some money
towards it i'm going to include one of
those kind of pay what you want buttons
so yeah if you want to buy me a coffee
to say thanks then they'll be much
appreciated so here's the app i'm
calling it biomind because i'm a nerd
it's in a kind of incomplete state i've
been working on it just over the last
couple of days haven't had a lot of time
so you know in future i'd like to add to
this and build on it and if you check
back to that page then i should have you
know newer versions coming out i might
also upload it to something like github
so we can work on it together it'll be
open source so maybe i'll include the
source files what we have so far is a
game with four different modes and the
first mode is the simplest you have to
count two different colored squares and
ignore a third color of square every
time one of those color squares which is
seven in total you tap the corresponding
button that will set that lots of
squares back to zero and you have to
keep track of the other lot of squares
at the same time i mean in this case
it's not that much different from dual n
back and indeed this is not a perfect
solution by any means i just think it
covers a few more different things than
dual and back as we'll see scenario
number two is similar you're keeping
track of three different squares however
in both scenarios you also have
distractors these are coloured squares
that pop up that you need to ignore
scenario three is where things get more
interesting because here you're not only
accounting two different coloured
squares again
but you're also ignoring a coloured
square but you're also counting the
total number of squares so when a green
square crops up you need to ignore that
as a colored square but you need to
count it towards the overall total
number of squares this is where your
brain starts to really struggle or mine
does anyways because you're juggling
different types of information you're
counting in a straightforward manner but
you're also thinking in terms of
semantics and what it means and you're
updating different information you're
avoiding distractors you're switching
between different tasks and this is
where i think it is a little bit more
comprehensive maybe than just your lend
back then in the fourth condition you're
tracking squares again we also have
sounds you have to identify when the
sound is say an animal versus just a
random sound you have to do this on top
of also keeping track of the squares
this is quite basic at the moment so
it's not a million miles beyond jewel
and back but hopefully you can see the
potential for it because you could also
have it where you're you know looking
for numbers that are even versus odd at
the same time tracking squares of
certain colors and total number of
squares and also sorting different
sounds out so there's lots of different
things you could be doing all at once
using different senses and like i say
because we're not just updating one data
set because we're juggling multiple it's
a bit more similar to how we use working
memory in real life but we don't just
get to focus on one thing we have to
switch between those things before we go
i also wanted to touch on a couple of
things we can do in the short term to
quickly boost our working memory one of
the most important things is tackling
stress because stress actually inhibits
activity in the prefrontal cortex which
can impair a lot of working memory this
is why the other day when i try to
collect my wife's prescription from the
doctors and they asked me her date of
birth i just froze because i mean
apparently i'm not socially anxious that
that alone was enough to create enough
stress that i couldn't access this thing
that i genuinely do know i do know my
wife's birthday i do in a more serious
situation we might imagine a fighter
pilot who's perfectly capable of
operating the many many controls that
they need to steer their craft but when
they're under fire suddenly all that
falls out the back of their head this is
called cognitive load and it's something
we need to consider from a design point
of view just because something is easy
to use in the moment is it easy to use
under stress at which point are working
memory is severely blunted this also
means that caffeine can actually blunt
working memory we think of caffeine as a
neuroenhancer as a neurotropic but
actually whilst it can improve working
memory for basic tasks as the cognitive
load gets greater the impact of caffeine
becomes more negative and actually
impairs performance so if you drink a
ton of coffee especially if you're
already an anxious person you're
actually going to become more jittery
less focused less quick to respond all
the things you would imagine that
caffeine would help with in some ways
working memory and focus are so
intertwined is to be almost inseparable
and meditation of course can help with
this greatly however like i say we also
need to be able to switch attention and
this is why i think that meditation on
its own might not be enough
there you go guys that's working memory
in a nutshell and how we can improve it
based on what we know so far i'm going
to be trying the things i recommended
here i'm going to invite you guys to do
the same and i'd love to know what your
results are if you found this
interesting or useful then please leave
a like and share around these videos
don't perform anywhere near as well as
my exercise tutorials but it's something
i want to keep doing so if you like this
kind of content then please share it
around i greatly appreciate it if you're
interested in training the brain and the
body then you might enjoy my ebook and
training program super functional
training 2.0 which also comes with over
two hours of instructional video that
has a brain training component and the
exercises are chosen specifically
because they have a cognitive benefit as
well as a physical one so if you're
interested in this kind of thing check
it out i'll put a link in the
description down below either way thank
you so much for watching this one guys
and i'll see you next time
bye for now